and we actually begin with some breaking
news kirsten
a neighborhood evacuated as police
investigate as an armed suspect has
barricaded himself in a home on york
wood drive that is near alexander road
and valley drive we're going to
send it right over to sasha loftis who
joins us live with an update sasha
brian and kirsten good afternoon it is
still a fluid situation out here in
north las vegas you can see
there are north las vegas police and
swat team members
on scene in this neighborhood here in
north las vegas
now we can hear a negotiator trying to
get
the man who police say is armed out of
this home
now police say he has discharged that
firearm
but no one has been hit at this time
police sources tell us there are several
family members inside or
several family members that he has tried
to shoot but again no one
has been injured at this moment now of
neighbors around this house have
directly
been evacuated that you can see though
that our neighbors that are outside of
that zone that are still in their homes
but they have just really come out and
kind of watching this situation unfold
as we are now again this is all
preliminary information but again
no civilians or police officers hurt at
this time
there is an armed man inside a home they
are trying to get him to come out we can
hear that negotiator still talking
we will of course keep you posted from a
safe distance here up in north las vegas
and bring you the latest
on air and online for now reporting live
sasha loftis
8 news now